What happened there?
Are you ok?
It's in!
I got it on!
Okay so the one who breaks the egg first...
Looses.
So...
I won
That's an easy win for me
Thank you Miikka
Good match Otto!
Let's go back inside
I don't want it anymore!
Sorry!
That hurt!
Felt like my hand came off!
And the first one...
I had like this one and this one
It bounced from this one and hit this one
Ah okay...
Hello
Tiktok!
Okay Miikka
You ready for this?
I've never been more ready in my whole life Otto!
Okay no no... I wasn't ready
Nice one Otto
Thanks
Otto
Mic check!
Yea, working!
I trusted you!
This is your side!
It's gonna work!
Almost dropped it
Pirate down!
I have been acting all these years
But this is my normal voice
Hello!
And guys
We heard there's still a lot of you
Who haven't subscribed
Don't, don't do that!
Remember to subscribe!
Oh, I lost my upper part
So help Pongfinity
And subcribe to our channel
I'm wrong way around now!
It's 4 am
And we're tired!
We still have 1 hour of cleaning to do!
Wohoo!
He's watching me like a hawk!
I could do that like when I was 4 years old
Awww
So cute!
Lovely
With one bounce
Let's start with the basics!
Almost
I just need one ball!
Jackpot!
I can't tell are you the edge guy
Or the ball breaker guy?
Let's go!
What did you say Otto?
I said: ? ? ?
What?
Subscribe to Pongfinity
Okay, I got it!
Just missed it a tiny bit!
And guys if you want to get one of these...
Skip the weights
Skip the dumbbells
All you need is a Pongfinity Stretchatron 5000!
5 reps a day is all you need!
And it's so easy to use!
You can show up to the gym looking cool
Looking trendy
Cut!
That didn't happen
This is wind ping pong!
It actually came on table!
And we are ready!
It broke
What?
Just kidding
How can we like keep the game going?
Like this!
It actually works!
I don't... want to show my fingernails
I love those fingernails!
Yea, thank you!
My favorite color!
I didn't know what I was filming
I've actually done nothing there!
I really wanted to hit!
Jackpot!
Nice block from the table!
Ok, I'll set the score for Miikka to try and beat
That's two
Here we have the real Sensei
And Sensei Padawan
No!
May the best backhand win!
Jackpot!
Straight in the eye
Sorry!
Where should I have my arms?
You can have them up here
You can buy these from pongfinity.store
And during the first 24 hours we've got a special campaign
Where every single order gets a greeting card...
So for obvious reasons it's not allowed to move the table
Too good
Why are you laughing?
I was a bit left outside of the rally
Hello again
Well, those pop!
Leave your ideas for the next...
...below!
So today we are going to show you different ways
How to play table tennis alone
This one's not a very good fan
Oh, I pressed it off
That's why
Funny moments with Miikka part 592
For how long do you want me to keep doing this?
Guys remember to subscribe if you haven't done it already
Or otherwise
I will find you!
Okay...
Okay what's happening?
Take cover!
Otto looks like a mouse!
Ok I think we did okay
I think pretty... good!
How can you loose with that?
Team Bandana!
Yoda
I have been expecting you!
Much to learn you still have
Young padawan!
Trick shot ideas...
Not the trick shot ideas but the video idea
And... until next time!
Until next time!